no thank you so much for having me drew
i'm so excited to do what we're gonna do
today
i am your humble student teach us how to
make this
beautiful concoction that you're gonna
show us
well i am so excited to walk you through
my favorite color changing wild violet
syrup
it is so fun and it is so easy
so first we have our wild violets and we
are going
to take a cup of them and the way that
we are going to harness that beautiful
shade
is by pouring a cup of hot distilled
water on top of our
flowers in your pot
there we go now these guys are going to
sit
in their water overnight but if you're
super cool
like me and drew you're going to pull a
little switch
rooney
wow look at the color of this
it's stunning it's stunning so in order
to
harness that power we are going to take
our violet tea
we're going to pop it into a pot with
some hot water
in it and we're going to let that warm
up just
enough that this this very sweet cup of
sugar
will dissolve in it there we go
gonna go ahead and give that a pour
we're giving it a stir it's a really
good time to do a little do a little
dance
in the kitchen have a little one oh my
gosh
look at your moves drew you are invited
to my kitchen dance parties any old day
okay now what do i do i'm gonna go ahead
and pour it into my picture
okay i've got a picture right here
it pops
so now we are going to add our lemon
juice in and watch
that dark oh my gosh
it turned pink
it's so pretty and now
exactly we're gonna go ahead and add in
our water i have some ice in here too
and it pops
and now look at this gorgeous springtime
pink
lemonade with violets it's so
beautiful
for making this with me today drew this
is a dream
oh my gosh tell me how you feel about it
this is how you feel about it
okay that is insane right
that's the best lemonade i've ever had
in my life right
alexis nicole nelson thank you so much
and go to thedrewberrymoreshow.com for
the full recipe
and alexis's foraging tips thank you
so much and until we meet again